[موسيقى]
ايه ده انا ازعل المشاهدين اسعد الله
اوقاتكم بكل خير نستكمل هذه التغطيه
للانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه حيث تحتتدم
المعارك الانتخابيه في اكثر من ولايه
متارجحه سنكون معكم على مدى هذه الساعه
بمزيد من الشراحات والاطلالات على المشهد
الانتخابي الامريكي لمعرفه ماذا تقول
اليها الامور في الساعات والايام المقبله
فقد فتحت مراكز الاقتراح في الساحل الشرقي
الامريكي ابوابها امام الناخبين للادلاء
باصواتهم في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
بالكونغرس وقد صوت اكثر من 41 مليون شخص
بشكل مبكر في سبع واربعين اولاد
وشهدت عمليه التصويت رافعه حواليه 120
قضيه قانونيه اعتبارا من الثالث من نوفمبر
يتعلق معظمها بتقييد الوصول الى الاقتراع
ففي ولايتي بنسلفانيا تحث بعض المقاطعات
الناخبين على تصحيح بطاقات الاقتراع
الغيابيه ذات التواريخ المفقوده او غير
الصحيحه التي امرت المحكمه العليا في
الولايه بالغائها فيما رفض قاض في متشجن
دعوه قضائيه قدمها مرشح جمهوري بهدف الغاء
الاقتراع الغيابي في ديترويت
هذا وقد مددت مقاطعه كام في جورجيا موعد
التسليم النهائي لنحو 1000 بطاقه اقتراع
غيابين حتى الرابع عشر من نوفمبر نظرا
لتاخر ارسال بطاقات الاقتراع في البريد
اما في اريزونا فارسل وزير خارجيه الولايه
ثماني 10 احاله لتطبيق القانون تتعلق
بالترهيب بما في ذلك رساله تهديد لموظف
حكومي والعديد من النابي
هذا وقالت رئيسته مجلس النواب الامريكي
نانسي في مقابله مع شباب شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكي قالت ان الهجوم الوحشيه على
زوجها سيؤثر على قرارها بشان البقاء في
البنك بعد انتخابات التجديد النصفي كما
دعت لوسي الجمهوريين الى وقف المعلومات
المدله التي تغذي العنف السياسي وحتى
الامريكيين على التصويت للدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه فيما لم تكشف في روسيا عن
خطتها المستقبليه اذا خسر الحزب
الديمقراطي الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب حيث
يعتقد الكثرون
واخرين سيتناحون عن السلطه
وقبل ساعات اعزائي المشاهدين من انطلاق
انتخابات التجديد من النصفي للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كان الرئيس جو بايدن قد
قدم تقييما صريحا لفرص حزبه في الاحتفاظ
بالسيطره على مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ
قدامك
مروان
[موسيقى]
وقد قدم الرئيس
في يوم حسم الانتخابات النصفيه محذرا بان
هذه هي الفرصه الاخيره للدفاع عن الديمقرا
[موسيقى]
الزمالك
كان لها تاثير مختلف في اتجاهات التصويت
هنا
شريف بن سلمان مع كل الجمهوريين تبقى
رسائل الحزب واضحه لقعدته الانتخابيه
منعوا الاجهاض التضخم والاقتصاد الباهت
وارتفاع نسبه الجريمه بالاضافه الى شخص
الرئيس جودا
بالنسبه للحزب القديم العظيم كما يسمى هنا
قد لا يكون اسم ترامب مدرجا في بطاقه
الاقتراع لهذا العام ولكن ترامبيه او ما
يعرف بالماجا موجوده بشكل واضح
[موسيقى]
من الانجازات العظيمه عندما كان رئيسا
واعتقد انه اذا ما اعيد انتخابه مره جديده
فسيكون بامكانه تحقيق الكثير
ثري جيوبي
الجمهوري الحزب الجمهوري هو
85% ترامب
[موسيقى]
اختار بنفسه مرشح مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
الخبير الطبيه الشهير الدكتور
[تصفيق]
الحاكم بعد فوزه المفاجئ في الانتخابات
التمهيديه
كريستيانو الذي حضر هجوم السادس من يناير
2021 على الكونغرس ولعب دورا رئيسيا في
الجهود المبذوله لالغاء نتائج 2020 في
ولايه بنسلفانيا واذا ما فاز بمنصب الحاكم
فسيكون لديه سلطه كبيره في تنفيذ انتخابات
الولايه
الذهاب والاستمتاع بحياته بعد التقاعد
ولكنه يحب ويهتم كثيرانيا فترشح لمنصب
حاكم الولايه هو قائد بالفطره
للانتخابات في بنسلفانيا خاصيه مهمه من
الممكن ان تعتمد الغالبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي عليها في الولايات المعروفه
بمراكز التجمع السكانيه الكبرى وبصناعاتها
الاخذه في التدهور يحاول الجمهوريون ان
يستغل الوضع الاقتصادي واخفاقات بعيدا في
هذا المجال بالاضافه الى موضوع الاجهاض
وارتفاع نسبه الجريمه مواضيعه تهم الناخبه
في الريف المحافظ تاريخيا
سليمان العربيه
امين
او موجه شعبيه
لنضرب مثالا على ذلك في ولايه بنسلفانيا
يتنافسوا على منصب الحاكم الديمقراطي جوش
شابيرو مقابل الجمهوري المدعوم من ترامب
دوج مستريان
ويتفوق الديمقراطيه على الجمهوري باكثر من
عشر نقاط او 10% في استطلاعات الراي اي ان
المقعد ديمقراطي بشكل مؤقتا لكن اذا نظرنا
الى منصب عضو مجلس الشيوخ فيتنافس على
المنصب الديمقراطي جون فجر مان والجمهوري
المدعوم من ترامب
والهامش بينهما في استطلاعات الرئيسيه اقل
من واحد بالمئه
اذا التصويت ليس حسبيا بل على شخصيه
المرشح كان فاتر من متقدما في استطلاعات
الراي لكن مع ظهوره وهو يعاني اثناء
الحديث بسبب اصابته بجلطه دماغيه قبل خمسه
اشهر
تراجعت حظوضه اي اننا نشهد نفسا الناخب في
بنسلفانيا يصوت لحاكم ديمقراطي ويصوت في
نفس الوقت لعضو مجلس شيوخ جمهوري يدعمه
الرئيس السابق دونال ترامب
[موسيقى]
نور
ابعث يلا
[موسيقى]
يا وليد
[تصفيق]
الدكتور سامي نادر استاذ العلاقات استاذه
الاقتصاد والعلاقات الدوليه دكتور سامي
اهلا وسهلا بك مجددا عبر شاشه العربيه في
هذه التغطيه دكتور سامي فقط يعني قبل ان
اسالك عن الشق الاقتصادي في هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه فقط لنفهم المشاهدين
يعني من حيث الشكل لماذا هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه هذه المره مختلفه ومهمه جدا في
العاده البهجه والرهجه تكون للانتخابات
الرئاسيه ولكن هذه المره نرى ان لا الرهجه
كلها للانتخابات النصفيه لماذا
اعتقد لان اكثر من موضوع على المحاكم
منهما يتعلق بالوضع الداخلي الامريكي خاصه
مستقبل الحزب الجمهوري وبشكل اساسي
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد سنتين لان هذا
سوف نوعا ما يحسن من هو الرئيس المقبل او
من سوف يخوض سباق الرئاسي اذن هنالك كثير
من الابعاد في الداخل الامريكي ولكن هنالك
ايضا بعدا اساسيا يتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه
يتعلق بالحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا ودعم
الولايات المتحده لهذه الحرب ف همم اصبح
هناك يعني بين الديمقراطيين وبين الجمهوري
نوع من التمن مول صحيح هذا التمن مول يحدث
قبل الانتخابات او موعد الانتخابات لان
الهم الاول هو استقطاب
همم استقطاب الناخب الامريكي الذي همم هو
معني بموضوع الاقتصادي بشكل اولوي لا
يكترس بما يحدث خارج الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعتبر ان اا دعم او نفق المال
الامريكي خارج امريكا في لحظه يعيش
المواطن الامريكي انهيار في قدرته همم
الشرائيه لا يتحدث ذلك الدكتور سامي انا
على مستوى الشعارات التي نسمعها لم نكن
نسمع مثل هكذا شعارات في الحملات
الانتخابيه السابقه الان الديمقراطيه
مهدده بالانهيار البلاد في خطر رئيس بين
قال همم في حال فاز الجمهوريون السنتان
المقبلتان ستكون مرووعتين هذه شعارات
انتخابيه ام لا الامور همم تذهب بهذا
الاتجاه في الولايات المتحده بعد الذي
شاهدناه في 2020 من الانتخابات رئاسيه وما
قالت اليه الامور
اعتقد يعني هنالك ابعاد تتعلق
بما جراف في كانون الثاني من العام الماضي
في حين اشتاح البعض القاعده الجمهوريه
المبنى الكابيتول وبالتالي السؤال اليوم
اذا فاز همم الجمهوريون همم
المجلس الشيوخ وبمجلس النواب هل هو كما هو
متوقع هل سوف يتوقف التحقيق في هذا الامر
اهلا نفكر مساله بلغت الاهميه عن بعض
المرشحين اليوم همم على همم على مجلس
النواب وعلى مجلس الشيوخ هم من همم اتباع
ترامب الذين يعتقدون ان الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الماضيه سرقت منهم وبالتالي
بعضهم سوف يصل الى مركز نائب او الى همم
سوف يكون عض في مجلس الشيوخ وبالتالي ما
موقف هؤلاء من الرئيس الذين لا طالما
اعتبروه انه سرق الرئاسه ايضا يعني
الامل للاسف انا مضطر للمقاطعه ساعود اليك
بعد قليل ولكن اعزائي المشاهدين ننتقل بكم
مباشره الى نيويورك متابعه وقائع كلمات
للمرشحه الديمقراطيه كاتشل الى هناك
مباشره في المنام
في محاربه الجريمه هذه ليست مثل انتخابات
العمده ادم
زرنا مترو الانفاق السادس من يناير همم
ليس تاريخ الذي اعتقده لزياده تحدث عنه
اقصر هذا العام وكان دخلتها ولا ما سببه
اسبوع والجلاسماء مع المره الاولى حاكم
نيويورك هو الذي خارطه فيه في مساعده عمده
المدينه هذه العلاقه حتى على العمده نفسه
اذن كانت هذه كلمه مقتضبه للعضو في ال في
مجلس النواب عن الحزب الديمقراطي
كاتوهاتشل الدكتور سامي اعود اليك في سؤال
لاحد المتابعين على تويتر يسالك من حيث
الشكل ايضا لماذا نحن في العالم العربي
مهتمون بهذه الانتخابات النصفيه وتغطيتها
يعني ما علاقه العالم العربي والشرق
الاوسط بنتائج انتخابات محليه نصفيه في
الولايات المتحده
هذا سؤال مهم جدا لان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ما زالت لاعب اساسي على الساحه
الشرق اوسطيه وبالتالي وذلك فرق كبير او
تحول كبير في هذه السياسه في حال هذا
الجمهوريون او فازوا في هذه الانتخابات
لانه سوف يعطلون بشكل كبير اجنده الرئيس
بيضا وكل ما يعلم ان
الرئيس تختلف في مواضيع اساسيه عن اجنده
الحزب الجمهوري في ما يتعلق
بالشرق الاوسط يعني مولى الملفات التي سوف
تشهد انتكاسه هي الملف المتعلق بايران
ومحاوله الرئيس بيضا العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي اعتقد مساله من هذا النوع او هذا
الملف سوف يرحل بشكل همم كامل اذا فاز
الجمهوريون انا لديهم القدره على
تعطيل قرار همم اداره اداره بيدا في حدا
الموضوع وهنالك مواضيع همم اخرى على في
اهميه بمكان متعلقه بالتغيير المناخي او
حتى مساله الشرق الاوسط العلاقه مع شركاء
امريكا التقليديين في الاردن اعلم ان
العلاقه طيب همم فقط لكي لا يهمنا الوقت
همم الاطلال على شان الاقتصادي هل فعلا
برايك ووافق متابعتك ان العامل الاقتصادي
هو من سيقرر مصير الولايات المتارجه بمعنى
او بتعبير اخر ان الديمقراطيين سيدفعون
الثمن سياسات الرئيس جودا خصوصا في موضوع
الطاقه ام لا هذا كلام فيه تحمل على الحزب
الديمقراطي وعلى رئيس
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد ان العامل الاقتصادي هو
الناخب الاول رايناه في الماضي انه لازم
بموضوع الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه والدليل
على ذلك يعني ما حدث ايام الرئيس اتلتون
انتصر على الرئيس بوش الذي كان هو الفائز
بالحرب حرب الخليج الاولى ولكنه لم يفترس
لي الهم الاقتصادي وبالتالي استطاع الرئيس
كلينتون ان ينتسع منه هذا الانتصار العكس
تماما يحصل اليوم مع الحزب الجمهوري الحزب
الجمهوري يعول على فشل اداره
فشل له مسبباتها يعني
لم يكن على مستوى التحديات الكبيره
المتعلقه
الحرب في اوكرانيا بازمه همم كورونا
وبالتالي همم يبني ال- همم الحزب
الجمهوري على هذه همم المساله بشكل اساسي
ويحولها الى عنوان المعرض المعركه بينما
الرئيس بيدن ويحاول ان يخوضها تحت رايه
الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه ولكن ال- اا اولويه
بالنسبه للناخذ الامريكي البارحه كما
اليوم هي قدرته الشرائيه
في حال فاز الجمهوريون في هذه الانتخابات
الى
متوقعه في حال فاز الجمهوريون هل سيكون
ذلك توطئه او ريهارسل لعوده متوقعه للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب الى كرسي البيت
الابيض بمعنى ان هذه الانتخابات
في حال فاز بها الجمهوريون تعبد الطريق
امامه وهنا السؤال ما الذي يعنيه ذلك على
مستوى الموقف الامريكي من الحرف في
اوكرانيا في حال فاز الجمهوريه
في حال فاز اولا بالنسبه
للرئيس المقبل اعتقد قال لها بشكل غير
مباشر همم دونالد ترامب همم البارحه على
ما اعتقد انه همم انه في 15 من الشهر
الحالي سوف يقوم همم باعلان جدا مهم وهمم
والكل يترقب ان يعلن عن ترشحه الى اسد او
نيته بالترشح الى الرئاسه الجمهوريه اما
بالنسبه
للدعم التي يتلقاه الاوكرانيون من الاداره
الامريكيه في حال وصول الجمهوريون همم
اصول الجمهوريين عفوا اعتقد الامر محسوم
قال لها همم
القيادي في الحزب الجمهوري حينما قال انهم
سوف يتشددون في مساله المساعدات همم
موجهه الى اوكرانيا وبالتالي من المتوقع
ان ينحسر هذا همم الدعم وان تدفع امريكا
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه باتجاه طاوله مفاوضات
الدكتور سامي نادر وساده الاقتصاد
والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه كنت معي من بيروت
اعزائي المشاهدين اعاده تقسيم الدوائر
الانتخابيه عمليه معقده لكنها مفصليه
وتعتمد على معايره عده قد ترجح كافه حزب
على اخر في الكونغرس العرض التالي يشرح
لكم بشكل مبسط تلك العمليه للزميله روان
حمزه
مفهوم اساسي تقوم عليه الانتخابات
التشريعيه الامريكيه يعرف باعاده تقسيم
الدوائر الانتخابيه ويستند الى تعداد
سكاني يجرى كل عشر سنوات بحيث يكون لكل من
منطقه ممثل واحد على الاقل يمثلوا عدد
السكان
اعادته رسم حدود المقاطعات يعني خسارته او
ربح نحوي ثلاثه عشره ولايه لمقاعده في
الكونجرس اعتمادا على التغير السكاني فيها
فبعد التعداد السكاني الاحداث قلى عدد
الدوائر التنفسيه بين الاحزاب في شكل عام
واقتصرت على 34 منطقه فقط وذلك بما معدله
17 من تقع اقل من ما كانت عليه عند
استخدام الخرائط السابقه هذه المناطق
السبعه عشره حلت مكانها 9 مقاطعه جمهوريه
وثاني مقاطعه ديمقراطيه ولاعبت تكساس دورا
كبيرا في تراجع المناطق التنفسيه
فكانت تحويل 11 منطقه لكن جمهوريين اعادوا
رسم الخريطه لتبقى واحده فقط
واثبتت التجارب التاريخيه استفاده الحزب
المسيطر على المجالس التشريعيه في
الولايات من ترسيم الدوائر الانتخابيه
وبالفعل سيطره مجالس تشريعيه ذات اغلبيه
الجمهوريه على نحوي 30 ولايه اعطتهم
الكلمه الاخيره بشان اعاده تقسيم الدوائر
في 170 دائره
بينها الاسكا ومونتانانت لا تتبعوا قوانين
اعاده تقسيم الدوائر لامتلاكها ممثلا
واحدا فقط
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا انتقل بكم مباشره الان سماع كلمه
خاصه
نتحدث مع الجميع
كثيرين واشكرهم على تواجدينهم هنا
ساتحدث مع البعاظه وحتى في كولومبوس زرتو
الثلاثه واربعه
واغلق هاتفي
عن نتائج
كذلك نعم
جدا جدا
من نتائج اليوم هذا وتوقعين
لو كنت عضو المجلس همم الجمهوريين هناك
حديث كبيره عن البايدين
علينا ان نتعرف على جندب بعد ان نحقق
الفوز ولكن الاهم وخاض الاسعار لسكاني
عوده
نظام القانون والدعم الشرطه بينما يضعون
المجرمين خلف القضبان هذا هو تركيزنا هو
يجب ان كنا مستعدين لاستخدام الغالبيه
التي سمنحوها لنا الشعب الامريكي تحقيق
هذه الامور ولكن هذا ما يجب ان يركز عليه
هو تحسين حياه البشر شكرا
اذا كنا مع هذه الكلمه همم طبعا المرشحين
دائما في جولاتهم الانتخابيه يحثون ويدعون
الناخبين او مناصرهم للتصويت بكثافه كنا
نستمع الى جيفانس مرشح عن المقعد الجمهوري
في ولايه اوهاي ازال مشاهدين
فاصل وهذه التغطيه الخاصه في الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه ارجو ان تتفضلوا
بالبقايا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تشكل سيطره احد الحزبين
الجمهوري او الديمقراطيه على الكونجرس او
على احد مجلسيه عاملا قد يكون مؤثرا في
السياسه الخارجيه للاداره الامريكيه خصوصا
اذا كان الحزب المسيطر معارضا لمقاربه
اداره الرئيس لقضيه التفاصيل مع الزميل
حسين الطيب
من المتوقع ان يكون لنتائج انتخابات
التجديد النصفي في الكونجرس تاثيرات على
قضايا متعلقه بسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
اذا سيطر الجمهوريون على احد المجلس
السائل او على كليهما فتغيره توازن القوى
داخل المؤسسه التشريعيه سيصاحب على
الاداره الامريكيه اتخاذا بعض القرارات
ابرز القضايا العوده الى الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران الذي يرفضه الجمهوريون بالاجماع
باعتباره ضعيفا ولا يخدم مصلحه الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في الشرق الاوسط
المتحفظين عليه لكونه لا يعالج سلوك ايران
المزعزي على الاستقرار والامن حيث يتعهد
الجمهوريون بعرقله الاتفاق اذا لم يطرح
على الكونجرس لمراجعته او يقرر كم معاهده
لكنها عرقله الاتفاق تتطلب اغلبيه الثلثين
في المجلسين اي سبعه 67 صوتا في مجلس
الشيوخ و 290 صوتا في مجلس النواب ومن غير
المرجح اذا فاز الجمهوريون ان يحصل على
هذه الارقام فعدد الديمقراطيين الرافدين
للاتفاق لا يعوض نقص
لا يمكن للجمهوريين اذا حققوا انتصارا في
الانتخابات النصفيه ان يمنع الاداره من
العوده الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
فموجب التشريع الذي تم تمريره عام 2015
ويسمى اينار لا تحتاج الاداره الى تصويت
ثلاثي الاعضاء وهم يتطلبه اقرار معاهده
دعم اوكرانيا هو الاخر يشهد مزيدا من
التحفظ عليه اذا فاز الجمهوريون فصحيح انه
يلقى تايدا واسعا من الحزبين لكن هناك
معارضه متزايده له في الحزب الجمهوريه
بسبب التكلفه غير المسبقه خاصه في ظل
التضخم في الصلب هذه المعارضه تيار ترامب
الانعزاليه الداعيه الى التركيز على
الشؤون الداخليه بدلت تدخلات الخارجيه ومن
ابرز مؤيديه السنه جورج هولي والسيناتور
رانبول اللداني صوت ضد المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا
في مجلس النواب وفي مجلس الشيوخ الذين
يريدون فقط رؤيه بعدا يواجه مشاكل و
سيصاحبون الامور عليه لكن بصراحه لا ارى
تحديدا خطيرا لاستمرار دعم الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا
بعض الجمهوريين يدعون الى انفاق الاموال
في مواجهه الصين بدل اوكرانيا وهنا يبرز
ملف دعم تايوان حيث كان لافتا تاييد 26
عضو جمهوريا في مجلس الشيوخ لزياره رئيسه
مجلس النواب الديمقراطيه نانسي فلوسي الى
الجزيره حسين الروض العربيه واشنطن
القضايا ستبحثها ناديه البلبيسي معكم مع
ضيوفها من واشنطن فالى ناديه مباشره الى
عاصمه القرار الى واشنطن ناديه الميكروفون
التي تفضل
شكرا لك الطالب عزاء المشاهدين اهلا بكم
في هذه الساعه الثانيه من التغطيه
المستمره على شاشه العربيه من استديوهاتنا
هنا في واشنطن طبعا سنتحدث حسب استطلاعات
الراي اذا فاز الجمهوريه بمجلس النواب كما
هو متوقع سيكون لدينا رئيس مجلس جديد وكيف
المقافي ستغيب السيده الحديديه اذا اردنا
وصفه وهي نانسي فلوسي عن المجلس قالت بنا
قد تستقيل لم تقرر بعد ماذا ستفعل لكن
موضوع السياسه الخارجيه هل سيتغير في
المجلسين سواء كان في النواب او في الشيوخ
طبعا سنناقش هذا الملف مع ضيفنا هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور وليد فارس باحث الشؤون
السياسي
الخليجيه الامريكيه ومستشار سابق للرئيس
ترامب وبون سالم همم رئيس مجلس همم رئيس
معهد الشرق الاوسط اهلا بكم ما في هذه
الساعه همم نتحدث عن السياسه الخارجي الكل
يتوقع بانه ستنقلب السياسه الخارجيه راسا
عقب اذا وصل الجمهوريون الى مجلس النواب
او حتى الى مجلس جوك بس نتحدث عن مجلس
النواب هل موضوع مثلا نبدا بموضوع ايران
هل سيتغير موضوع ايران هل سيكون هناك
معارضه للرئيس اذا كان هناك اي طريقه
للتواصل الى اتفاق والعوده لاتفاق النووي
ابدا معك دكتور وليد
20 سنه الماضيه تغيير قياده او اكثر او
مجلس الشيوخ بيحدث ذاتها لن تمنع اضاء
الاداره من ان تستمر في سياستها الخارجيه
وراينا ذلك مع بوش مع اوباما وحتى مع
ترامب ولكن بعض الامور قد تتغير وحسب على
ماذا سوف يسيطر الجمهوريه اليوم اذا سدروا
على مجلس النواب يسيطرون على الماء
وبواسطه المال يضغطون على الاداره ولكن
اذا السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ يجرون على
التعيينات هذه بامكان ان يرفضوا او لا
يرفضوا وعلى توقيع المعاهده الان جوابا
لسؤالك همم اعتقد انه لن يكون للرئيس بعد
هذه الانتخابات حذف تمرير اي معاهده مع
ايران في هذا المجلس لعامين ولكن هذا لا
يمنع مثلا ان يقوم بقرار تنفيذ هذا مثل
واحد من الامثل
بول الرئيس اوباما الرئيس اوباما عندما
وقع الاتفاق مع ايران همم كان لم يكن
معاهده كان اتفاق لماذا لانه بحاجه الى
مصادقه كل شيء اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ ولم
يستطع الحصول على ذلك اذا قرر ان تكون ان
يكون اتفاق وليس معاهده هذا لا نرى اي
تغيير في مجلس الشوب حتى لو سيطره
الجمهوري عليه اليس كذلك صحيح يعني كما
ذكر الدكتور وليد تاثير مجلس النواب ومجلس
الشيوخ له تاثير في السياسه الخارجيه ولكن
تاثير محدود السياسه الخارجيه في الدستور
الامريكي هي صلاحيه رئيس الجمهوريه مجلس
النواب له دور في المال كما ذكر الدكتور
وليد وهذا قد يؤثر بمساعدات لي اوكرانيا
ومساعدات لمصر او مساعدات اخرى ولكن همم
الاخرى معظمها في يد همم
السلطه التنفيذيه اللي هي الكونغرس ايضا
دور في تاخير او عرقله الصفقات العسكريه
وهذا شيء مهم بالاخص بما يتعلق بالعلاقات
الامريكيه الخليجيه لا يعني من الصعوبه ان
يمنع صفقه همم كبيره لانه هذا يحتاج الى
ثلثين المجلسين وهذا امر مستحيل العمليه
ولكن يعرف يعقل ويؤثر همم في الواقع لن
تؤثر هذه الانتخابات كثيرا على السياسه
الخارجيه اولا لانه تاثير الكونجرس محدود
ولكن ايضا رغم التناقضات الشديده همم في
السياسه الداخليه بين الحزبين في المواقف
في العلاقات الخارجيه والسياسه الخارجيه
من ال- يعني الملفات ان العلاقه ان
المواقف ليست متباعده جدا همم اولا
بالمواقف في العالميه الموقف من
الاوكرانيا قريب بين الحزب الجمهوري
والديكوراتي الموقف الصين موقف مشابه وفي
الملف الايراني منذ عامين كان الحزب
الديمقراطي متفائل بصفقه مع ايران ولكن
بالوقت الحاضر اداره بيادر والحزب
الديمقراطي اصبح تقريبا يائسا من اي صفقه
وبعد يعني الانتفاضه واللي ما يحصل في
الداخل الايراني ودعم ايران لروسيه في
اوكرانيا حتى الحزب الديمقراطي اصبح بعيدا
جدا عن اجواء
اوكرانيا
يكون رئيس مجلس النواب القادم الذي قال لم
نستطيع ان نقدم شيكا على بياض ليكرانيا
وتراجع نوعا ما في مقابله حديثه وقال لاي
دوله ليس فقط لاوكرانيا لكنهم يا سيطرون
على الميزانيه كما ذكر بس عوده سريعه
للملف الايراني يعني الاداره كما قلت ونحن
نعرف همم من متابعتنا ل- وحديثنا مع ال
البيت الابيض وزاره الخارجيه بان موضوع
العوده الى الاتفاق صعب الان بسبب
التظاهرات في ايران وبسبب الوضع بشكل عام
والشروط الايرانيه وبالتالي لا نتوقع ان
يكون هناك حديث مره اخرى عدا ان هناك سقور
في الديمقراطين مثل السنه الميلاديس
وغيرهم ايضا لا يريدون ان يكون هناك عوده
الى الاتفاق لكن بنسبه مواضيع بشكل اوسط
نتحدث عن امن الخليج يعني هل سنرى تغيير
كبير في امن الخليج وتعود اليك بول لانك
كتبت على هذه النقطه بالحديد دكتور وليد
ايجابي لانه مجلس النوابته هو يتعاطى
الموضوع همم الامور الماليه والمساعدات
وهو ليس موضوع مساعدات ولكن الصفقات ووراء
الصفقات هنالك شركه واجوريون معروفون
بدعمهم لهذه الشركات اذا انا سوف ارى ان
هنالك سببا ان لم يكن ثلاثه لماذا مجلس
النواب سوف يدعم سياسه ايجابيه تجاه
الخليج اولا الصفقات الماليه والمعاهدات
ثانيا معاهده ابراهيم
عهد ابراهيم الى لها كثير من الدعم داخل
مجلس النواب همم وهذا امر غريب لانه هذا
الدعم ياتي من القواعد المحافظه بمجرد
وجود اسرائيل وبالتالي هنالك الامارات
فسوف يتخذون هذا هذا الدعم ثالثا سوف
يدعمون الخليج اكثر لان هنالك اكثر في هذا
المجلس الاتي ضد ليس فقط الاتفاق النووي
ولكن ضد النظام الايراني وللمعارضه
الايرانيه ايضا دور كبير اذا سنرى اكثر
فعاليه في العلاقات الامريكيه الخليجيه هل
تتفق بان التغيير سيكون ايجابي بالنسبه
لدول الخليج في اذا تغير تركيبه المجلس
يعني الاجواء ايجابيه اكثر من قبل الحزب
الجمهوري الاتجاه دول الخليج هذا امر
معروف همم مواقف اشد بالنسبه لايران ولكن
يعني التغيير الاساسي الذي حصل في السنوات
القديمه حصل ايام اوباما او ايام الرئيس
ترامب ايام الرئيس بعدين هناك تراجع امير
كي من همم عمليه سمي سياسه كارتر اذاكر
وهي تقول ان الولايات المتحده تدافع عن
عمليه يعني عمليا دول الخليج الى حد ما في
ايام الرئيس ترامب عندما حصل الهجوم مباشر
على ارامكو وادار النفط هجوم مباشر على
الملاحه في الخليج لم يكون هناك رد من
اداره الترام في شكل الفعال وفي ايام
الرئيس بعيدا عندما حصل هجوم على ابو ظبي
وعلى الامارات ايضا لم يخسر الولايات
المتحده باقي في الخليج وليس اسباب بعيده
الامل واسباب لها باسواق النفط ومستقبل
الصراع مع الصين نصف النفط الصيني ياتي من
الخليل والاستور الامريكي لا يريد ان يترك
هذه الموقع المهم والمهم جدا همم ولكن همم
يعني مشكله امن دول الخليج لا تزال قائمه
مع الجمهوريه ومع
الديمقراطيين لانه التحدي والخطا الاتي من
ايران وقطر الحقيقي جزء منه عبر يعني
منظمات غير النظاميه ولكن جزء عبر الانظمه
صاروخيه وربما برنامج نووي
ديمقراطين ولا الجمهوريين وجدوا حل لا
للبرنامج النووي ولا لهذا التحدي همم
فالمشكله قائمه معه
اعود مره اخرى
الموضوع مهم جدا استقرار اسعار الطاقه وهي
مشكله الاساسيه للرئيس انه بالنهايه نتحدث
عن الديمقراطيه في خطر الى اخره لكن
بالنسبه للمواطن الامريكي الذي سيذهب الى
صناديق الاقتراع اليوم وبالنسبه لوجيبته
يعني اسعار النفط ارتفعت الاسعار المواد
الغذائيه الكماليه اسعار فواتير الكهرباء
والغاز والاخرين هل سنرى تغيير سواء كان
بمجلس النواب او في مجلس الشيوخ من العوده
مره اخرى لطرح الجمهوريين بانه يجب ان
ننقب على النفط الصخري والاكتفاء الذاتي
الامريكي الذي حقق في عهد الرئيس ترامب او
انس- نجد معارضه وموضوع البيئه والمناخ
والى اخره من قبل الديمقراطيه
من جانب او رؤيه النخبين انه سيكون مهمين
من سوف ينتخب هذه الاكثريه له رؤيه قد لا
تكون لا رؤيه ولا رؤيه ناقدي بيض وهي
التاليه هم يريد ان اثريتها هؤلاء
المحافظين يريدو ان تبدا عمليه التنقيب او
العمل على انتاج في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعني لن تكون المساله نريد ان
نضغط على المملكه العربيه السعوديه لكي
تنتج اكثر او نريد ان لا نضغط عليها ستكون
نريد الانتاج هنا وبالتالي فان هؤلاء
النواب حسب من سوف ياتي في رئاسه اللجان
لانه رئاسه اللجان الخارجيه والاقتصاد
بفعلا يكون له تاثير كبير على هذا الموضوع
هم الذين اذا كانوا من اي مدرسه ولكن على
الاقل في خطاب السياسي في المجلسان على
الاقل الجمهوريين سوف يقولون نحن الان في
في صدقه الضغط على الاداره الانتاج المحلي
يبقى موضوع تصنيف الحوثيين كمنظم ارهابيه
موضوع طرح كثيره يعني اذا تحدثنا لي سفراء
في دول الخليج وغيرها يريدون لهذه الاداره
بالفعل ان تدرجهم على قوائم الارهاب لانه
حتى الان لم ياتوا الى طاوله المفاوضات
نعرف حجه الاداره بانها تقول بانه من
ناحيه انسانيه المساعده لن تصل الى اليمن
اذا كانوا هم على هذه القوائم ويريد ان
يساعدوهم يعني تمرين تركيين ذهب الى
المنطقه يمكن اكثر نعد من الجولان لكن هل
ترى بانه التغيير في المجلس همم منه
بالتحديد سيغير كثيرا هل يمكن ان نسمع
دعوات حتى في مجلس الشيوخ من قبل كروز
وغيرهم في تصنيفهم اما ان لا تعتبر انه
هذا خطاب ليس اكثر وبالنهايه لن يتغير شيء
من امريكا
من ايران وكلاء ايران
له علاقه بالحزبين والحزب الجمهوري بموقفه
المتشدد ضد ايران وهو يعني لديه موقف
متشدد من الحوثيين وسيكون هناك دعوه من
بعض الجمهوريين يعني اعاده الحوثيين الى
قائمه العراق وعلى اداره بيضا ان يعني
تلعب اللعبه السياسيه وتعرف كيف تتعامل مع
الدخول اظن ان تملا تركينج والمفاودين
بالشكل اليمني وهم جديين بمحاوله ايجاد
مخرج للازمه اليمنيه بعد التقدم اللي حصل
لتهدئه ووقفه نار وهذا امر مهم بالنسبه
للشعب اليمني وهناك لا تزال امال بايجاد
مخرج الحرب اليمنيه لا شك ان الامر ايضا
بالنسبه لاداره بيض المرتبط بالمفاوضات
معينه
على الامل ويعني وانقطع التفاوض مع
الايرانيين قد يكون اسهل عند اذن اداره
واذا بالاخص لم يكون هناك تقدم مهم في
اليمن ان يحصل هذا الامر ولكن كما ذكرنا
هذا امر غير مطروح الان في الاجواء
السياسيه الانتخابيه هو موضوع السياسي
الخارجي
الا اذا كان يتعلق بالارهاب
اسرائيل مثلا موق
فه مثل هذه
اليوم
اليسار
الديمقراطي التقدمي
لاول مره في التاريخ الامريكي الحديث لا
هم واقف متشدده جدا من السياسه
الاسرائيليه همم وداعمه للقضيه الرئيس
لا اسرائيل طبعا
لاول مره بالسياسه الامريكيه في موقف مهم
مضبوط بس اذا اعتبرنا هذه الانتخابات ايضا
هي
تعبيد الطريق امام 20 24 بمعنى بانه اذا
خسروا
الديمقراطيين المجلسين هناك اصوات سترتفع
وتقول بانه الرئيس يجب عليه ان يتنحى ربما
يضع همم او يعطي الفرصه لشخص اخر لياخذ
مكانه وايضا الرئيس ترامب ينتظر بالنسبه
لي مؤيدين همم كما قلنا اعراب الحزب
الجمهوري يسيطر عليه بشكل كبير لكن الرئيس
الحاليا اذا قلنا السياسه الخارجيه
بالتحديد همم شو العنوان الاساسي اللي
نجحته بالسياسه الخارجي
محللين مدار محايد يعني انا برايي انا هو
التضامن الاطلسي يعني هو دعم اوكرانيا
وذهب الى الناتو
روسيا بغزوه الى اوكرانيا
مهمه عدم تشدده في الاشتباك والتصعيد مع
روسي على الصعيد النووي حيث يعني هذه امر
ليس شعبه وليس هوت كما يقال ولكن على
الرئيس ان يكون واعا لهذا الموضوع وبنفس
الشئ بالنسبه للصين الصين وروسيا في
الموضوع النووي يجب ان يكون رئيس في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تصعيد يعني ليس من مصلحه احد
على فكره
الى روسيا عفوا الى اوروبا والحديث مع فتح
حوار مع روسيا بالنسبه هل نعتبر بانه هذا
الخطر تمتوائه
الدكتور من الروس هم وبانتظار ان نكون ذلك
اي تحرك لان هم يريدوا هددنا بالنووي وهم
ينتظرون الامريكيين ان يدخلوا لهم لا لن
نصعد اكيد همم يجب ان نعود الى دول بشيء
بدبي بشكل سريع دكتور فوز بالنسبه للخطر
انه حتى انجازات الرئيس الخارجيه هل
احتواها بالنسبه لروسيا اولا الجينز براي
تاريخي انه هذا اكبر تهديد للامن الاوروبي
ونوعا ما نزار العالميه منذ انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي او الحرب البارده
ويعني فعلا احسن اداره العلاقات الدوليه
الموضوع اكثر
ما يجب ان نعود الى دبي اليك الطالب وطبعا
هذه التغطيه مستمره على شاشه العربيه حتى
صدور النتائج شكرا لك ناديه ولضيفيكي
اعزائي المشاهدين قبل ان نختم هذه الصور
وردتنا منذ قليل للسنه ترتذكر رموز حيث
تعرض موكبه في تكساس لالقاء زجاجات فارغه
وعلب مشروبات فارغه اذا الموكب الانتخابي
لسنه ترتذكر روز في تكساس يتعرض لرشق
بالمستوى عباءات همم المستبعات المشروبات
الفارغه على كلنا اعزائي المشاهدين هذه
التغطيه مستمره عبر قناه العربيه ارجو ان
تتفضلوا بالبقاء معنا بعد قليل ساعه تغطيه
ايضا لهذه الانتخابات التحيات والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]